[Música]
a
escala en parís aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 hoy les hablamos de ciencia ética y
política con uno de los científicos
argentinos más importantes de su
generación que acaba de integrar la
academia francesa de las ciencias además
lidera un equipo que ha descubierto un
importante hallazgo y científico para el
tratamiento de la atrofia muscular
espinal hoy hace escala en parís alberto
kornblihtt muchísimas gracias alberto
por estar con nosotros ustedes el placer
es mío bueno usted tiene 67 años es
investigador del conicet principal
organismo de promoción de la ciencia de
la tecnología en argentina es profesor
en la universidad de buenos aires y
trabaja y dirigió el instituto de
fisiología biología molecular y
neurociencias amante del cine de la
literatura y gran conocedor del latín su
trabajo ha sido reconocido y premiado en
todo el mundo y un periodista argentino
ha leído le llamó una vez el mes y de
las ciencias no sé si se reconoce
la verdad que debo aclarar que ese
periodista es amigo mío es lo dijo en un
evento digamos
de la televisión para decir que el
público no debía solamente pensar en los
deportistas sino también en los
científicos así que a mí me da un poco
de vergüenza esa esa comparación pero la
verdad es que también es cierto que aún
messi necesita de un equipo para poder
jugar bien y en mi caso obviamente yo no
podría haber hecho nada si no tuviera
mis discípulos y mis colegas y mi equipo
lleva 25 años investigando el
funcionamiento de l'esplai singh
alternativo que está en la base del
nuevo hallazgo para tratar la atrofia
muscular espinal explíquenos que es el
esplai sin alternativo lo que usted
suele llamar el sastre de nuestras
células
bueno nuestras células tienen más o
menos unos 20 mil genes que son trozos
de línea que se encuentra en el núcleo
ahora cada uno de esos genes a través de
un proceso muy complicado da la orden
para fabricar proteínas
hace 40 años se pensaba que cada gen
daba la orden para fabricar una proteína
pero cuando se descubrió este proceso se
encontró que en realidad cada gen puede
dar la orden para fabricar 23 decenas o
a veces centenares de proteínas
distintas el fenómeno que permite que
eso ocurra se llama splice in
alternativo que es una manera con el
cual el arn mensajero que es tan famoso
ahora porque se ha utilizado en las
bananas estáis hoy de modernas ela erne
mensajero que es producido por cada gen
es cortado y unido para formar una rn
más corto y ese es el que finalmente
forma la proteína ahora en ese corte y
unión que se llama splicing
el sastre que son las enzimas que pueden
hacerlo depende de donde corten y donde
unan pueden formar distintas
configuraciones es como si el sastre
pudiera fabricar chaquetas sacos pero
uno derecho y otro cruzado o sea es una
manera que tiene el sistema biológico de
aumentar la capacidad codificante de los
genes y por qué es tan importante les
place in alternativo en el hallazgo que
han hecho bueno en realidad la cura de
esta enfermedad tuvo un gran avance por
los resultados de un colega mío uruguayo
llamado adrian kreiner que trabaja en
eeuu y que encontró un
tenemos un oligonucleótidos un trozo de
dna que cuando se lo inyecta a los
pacientes le corrige el esplai sin
alternativo de un gen que permite que se
mitigue la mayor parte de los
digamos síntomas negativos porque es una
enfermedad muy devastadora que la
atrofia los músculos y afecta la
motricidad motricidad ahora ósea que el
gran hallazgo es el de él y eso fue
aprobado por las agencias europea y eeuu
y de todo el mundo en 2016 lo que
nosotros hemos publicado recientemente
en la encima en la perdón en la revista
'cell es que en nuestro laboratorio
había estudiado que la velocidad con que
se copia el gen es determinante para
como ocurre el esplai sin alternativo y
nosotros descubrimos que si hacemos que
la velocidad sea más rápida esa
corrección de l'esplai sin que encontró
kreiner sea aún mejor entonces por ahora
lo hemos hecho en células en cultivos y
en ratones experimentales que son
modelos de la enfermedad pero esperamos
que en algún momento se puede hacer un
ensayo clínico con pacientes
le va a preguntar cuándo y eso como yo
soy biólogo del laboratorio no es mi
dominio pero bueno los familiares de los
niños los propios familiares nucleados
tanto en la asociación norteamericana
como en la asociación argentina están
muy interesados en que pronto se
empiecen ensayos clínicos esta
investigación ha sido un tanto especial
para usted no porque fue a raíz de que
las familias vinieron a llamar un a su
puerta dijeron usted tiene que
investigar sobre esto nos va a ayudar y
esto ocurrió hace seis años y a partir
de la insistencia de la familia
finalmente nosotros empezamos en este
tema de la atrofia muscular de derecho
cuando ellos vinieron nos ya les dije
miren yo no les voy a vender espejitos
de colores ni prometerles la cura de
algo que no trabajo pero ellos
insistieron dijeron no nos importa
creemos que en la argentina alguien que
trabaja en splice en como como hizo
usted y aborde este tema porque a
nosotros nos viene bien y nos
financiaron y después obtuvimos muchos
créditos o subsidios internacionales y
la verdad que fueron ellos los artífices
y a mí me cambió la vida
bueno usted también ha publicado un
libro que se llama no no está bien está
mal una pasión argentina por la ciencia
y por el arte y la política en editorial
paperback fue publicada en 2021
sudamericana y es un libro bueno pues
sobre su vida sus pensamientos su
historia su historia y el título viene
de una frase que usted pronunció en mayo
de 2018 en el debate en el congreso
argentino sobre la ley de interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo y le respondí a
una senadora que durante la formulación
de su pregunta le iba a hacer una
pregunta a usted se asimila el síndrome
de dawn a una enfermedad incurable esa
frase se hizo viral usted pensó que iba
a tener tanta repercusión cuando la
pronuncia no pensé que iba a tener tanta
repercusión
yo no tengo redes sociales más que
whatsapp
mail que no es una red social y me
sorprendió muchísimo hasta que algunos
jóvenes hicieron camisetas con mi cara
diciendo eso en realidad no no está bien
está mal es porque estás ahora que es
antiderechos puso en mi boca palabras
que yo no había dicho en mi exposición y
entonces en un momento dado al yo
decirle que no había dicho eso que yo no
estaba a favor de promover el aborto
sino que el aborto en un derecho de las
mujeres que debía ser respetado de las
mujeres y de la sociedad no sólo de las
mujeres ella dijo bueno bueno está bien
y yo digo no no está bien está mal y
usted cree que se escucha lo suficiente
los científicos bueno ha habido una
reacción del mundo científico frente a
la pandemia sobre todo en mi país que ha
permitido una visibilidad mucho mayor en
la sociedad yo creo que sí que que la
lamentablemente fue la pandemia pero ha
habido una participación de los
científicos en los medios de difusión en
los grandes diarios en la televisión
muchas veces con la necesidad de
corregir o desmentir no digamos fake
news pero sí afirmaciones livianas
personas que están involucradas a veces
en el periodismo a veces en la política
y que afirmaban cosas que no eran
correctas entonces era necesario que los
científicos apareciéramos no para
pontificar no para decir que tenemos la
única verdad pero sí para aclarar cuando
hay una confusión que justamente a lo
largo de la historia la ciencia ha sido
víctima a veces no de campañas
religiosas campañas políticas morales
luchas políticas incluso en la edad
media en europa se quemaban los llamaban
brujos brujas y en esta pandemia de
coronavirus si bien se ha escuchado
mucho a los científicos también ha
habido una ola de gente que ha
desconfiado mucho primero de que ese
virus existiera otro si existe pero
estaban en contra de las vacunas que las
vacunas no sirven para nada que sólo es
para
enriquecer a las farmacéuticas
había una especie de ola de rechazo a
todo eso como lo explica cuando estamos
en una sociedad
que en el a cambio de progresos
científicos vivimos más tiempo mejor yo
creo que aquí se mezcla ese problema con
el tema que se puso sobre a la mesa el
conflicto entre las libertades
individuales y las libertades como un
bien colectivo y social obviamente yo
pienso que la libertad es un bien
colectivo y social y con cuando yo me
vacuno no lo hago solamente para
protegerme a mí sino para contribuir a
que la enfermedad desaparezca o se
mitigue y para contribuir a la no
dispersión del virus entonces está esta
excesiva búsqueda del derecho individual
a decidir sobre el tema de la salud está
muy asociada al pensamiento de las
derechas y está muy potenciado también
por ciertos medios de difusión que no
son este imparciales respecto de esto
entonces si es un problema yo creo que
justamente cuando me incorporaron a la
academia de ciencias de francia en la
argentina el presidente de nación me
hizo un reconocimiento y yo pude hablar
y dije que este año se cumplen 200 años
del nacimiento de louis pasteur y louis
pasteur que fue el pionero de la
vacunación la gente golpeaba la puerta
de su gabinete en l'ecole normal aquí en
parís para ser vacunada contra la rabia
y eso indica que
sería un reto de un retraso en
la evolución de las sociedades que
apelará a lo individual y a la sospecha
de cosas que no han sido probadas para
evitar un bien colectivo que la
vacunación bueno ha viajado a parís
justamente para participar en la
ceremonia de recepción de los nuevos
miembros de la academia de las ciencias
francesa forma parte ya de la
estadounidense desde hace un tiempo esta
academia la francesa existe desde
1666 y es una especie de asamblea de
científicos que examina pues los retos
políticos éticos y sociales en torno a
esos retos científicos y avances
científicos actuales y futuros no
entonces usted gastado con los miembros
recientemente explíquenos que se dice
que se habla cuáles son las
preocupaciones de los científicos de
esta academia
y los retos también yo creo que bueno en
primer lugar hay un
un prestigio muy grande de la academia
que implica que quien es incorporado
bueno se siente como alguien
especialmente elegido por votación aquí
no hay nadie se auto propone o sea que
bueno si yo me enteré en diciembre de
año pasado por un mail que me mandó uno
de los académicos y fue
una gran felicidad bueno porque es el
reconocimiento de mis colegas pero
también es el reconocimiento de mis
colegas a alguien que está haciendo
ciencia a más de 10.000 kilómetros de
distancia y en un lugar que no es
central en la ciencia internacional yo
creo que los académicos están siempre
preocupados por aquellos aspectos
sociales de la ciencia en qué medida la
ciencia puede ser utilizada en contra de
los sectores más vulnerables o puede ser
ninguneada
considerada la ceremonia fue muy emotiva
muy especial yo trabajé toda mi familia
incluyendo a mi nieto y la verdad es que
fue un gran placer y tuve la oportunidad
y esto lo que confiesa ahora de que en
mi discurso que duraba cinco minutos al
principio que habla en francés me
refería a la importancia de la cultura
francesa porque para mí esto es una
posibilidad también de compartir un amor
que tengo por la cultura francesa desde
la música de georges pasando de
boliviano o las películas de años verdad
y creo que eso fue muy bien recibido
entonces yo siento que ahora soy como un
miembro de la casa y que puedo charlar
con ellos de otros problemas que no son
solamente la cultura francesa bueno pues
alberto kornblihtt muchísimas gracias
por haber estado con nosotros y le
deseamos muchísimo éxito bueno en todos
los ámbitos con su libro y también con
esa investigación que va a ser seguro
muy buena para
para tratar la atrofia muscular espinal
muchísimas gracias gracias y muchísimas
gracias a todos ustedes por habernos
acompañado ya saben que también nos
pueden seguir por internet en grecia y
mundo.com bien france24 puntocom hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]